>> Laura: THANKS FOR BEING
WITH US TONIGHT, I'M
LAURA INGRAHAM, THIS IS "THE
INGRAHAM ANGLE."
FEARING YOUR OWN PEOPLE, THAT'S
THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S ANGLE.
♪ ♪
[BLEEP] ♪ ♪
>> Laura: NINA JANKE WITTS,
BIDEN'S NEW DISINFORMATION CZAR
AT HOMELAND SECURITY, SHE IS OFF
KEY DOING A BAD JULIE ANDREWS
IMPERSONATION BUT IT'S OFF KEY
IN MORE WAYS THAN ONE.
IF WE ALL DIDN'T KNOW THIS WAS
REALLY HAPPENING, IF WE DIDN'T
JUST WITNESS THAT, WE WOULD
THINK THIS WAS SOME KIND OF
ORWELLIAN SPOOF OF WHAT PARANOID
CONSERVATIVES THINK THE
ESTABLISHMENT ON THE LEFT IS
PLANNING.
UP PART ANGRY FEMINIST, PART
FRUSTRATED KARAOKE SINGER, SHE'S
THE LAST PERSON WHO SHOULD BE
TRUSTED WITH DISTINGUISHING
BETWEEN FACT AND FICTION.
SHE'S A GRADUATE OF BRYN MAWR
COLLEGE, A CARICATURE OF THE
MODERN LEFT UNIVERSITY.
SHE WORKED AT THE WILSON CENTER,
A THINK TANK OF SORTS AND HAS A
COLLECTION OF ALL THE WORST
IDEAS ON FOREIGN POLICY.
IS AN EXPERT IN EURASIAN
AFFAIRS, YOU WOULD THINK SHE
WOULD AUTHOR ARTICLES MAY BE ON
THE IMPORTANCE OF PRESERVING
FREE EXPRESSION IN REPRESSIVE
REGIMES.
NOT QUITE, BUT SHE DID PUBLISH
THIS GYM.
MALIGN CREATIVITY, HOW GENDER,
SEX, AND LIES ARE WEAPONIZED
AGAINST WOMEN ONLINE, CAN'T WAIT
TO READ THAT.
SHE WORKS AS AN ADVISOR TO THE
UKRAINE FOREIGN MINISTER, WHAT?
MOST IMPORTANTLY FOR THE CURRENT
DAY, SHE IS HUNTER BIDEN'S
SCANDAL DENIER.
>> IS THIS THE SAME INDIVIDUAL
WHO SAID THE DOSSIER WAS REAL
END OF THE LAPTOP STORY WAS
FALSE, IS THAT THE INDIVIDUAL
WHO'S RUNNING THE
DISINFORMATION?
>> I'M NOT FULLY OR WITH THOSE
STATEMENTS.
>> IT'S BEEN REPORTED WIDELY.
>> I'M NOT FAMILIAR WITH THOSE.
>> Laura: I'M NOT FAMILIAR
WITH THAT.
YOUR ACCOUNT LET ME
ENLIGHTEN YOU.
WHAT THE NEW DISINFO CZAR SAID
ABOUT HUNTER BIDEN'S LAPTOP IS
WE SHOULD VIEW IT AS A TRUMP
CAMPAIGN PRODUCT.
SHE WANTS US TO EMULATE A
EUROPEAN STYLE MODEL OF HEAVY
REGULATION OF INTERNET CONTENT
DEEMED HARMFUL AND DANGEROUS.
THAT JUST MEANS CONTENT THAT
CONFLICTS WITH WHATEVER THE LEFT
BELIEVES ABOUT ISSUES LIKE
CLIMATE, ELECTIONS, RACE, AND
GENDER IDENTITY.
>> THE FIRST AMENDMENT DOES NOT
APPLY TO PRIVATE PLATFORMS AND
THEY COULD VERY EASILY DECIDE
THAT CLIMATE DENIAL AND OTHER
HARMFUL HATE SPEECH AND
MISINFORMATION IS NOT ALLOWED ON
THEIR PLATFORMS.
THEY HAVE DECIDED INSTEAD TO
ALLOW THIS FREE SPEECH FAIRY
DUST TO RAIN OVER THE PLATFORMS
AND I THINK THAT'S WHERE WE NEED
TO SEE REGULATION COME IN.
>> Laura: YOU SEE HOW SHE HAD
THAT LAUGH?
SOMEONE SHOULD GIVE HER A LESSON
IN BASIC ADMINISTRATIVE LAW.
IF IT WERE CONSTITUTION AS A
DELEGATION OF AUTHORITY FOR THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH TO EFFECTIVELY
OUTLAW CERTAIN TYPES OF SPEECH
IT DOESN'T LIKE OR DOESN'T AGREE
WITH, I KIND OF HAVE A FEELING
THAT PRESIDENT OBAMA WHO
ACTUALLY IS A HARVARD LAW
GRADUATE WOULD HAVE FIGURED THAT
OUT BEFORE THIS BIDEN BRYN MAWR
CROWD.
THE REAL STORY HERE IS BIGGER
THAN TICK-TOCK NEEDS AMERICA'S
GOT NO TALENT.
THE PROBLEM IS THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY ITSELF, SET UP
BY PRESIDENT BUSH AFTER 9/11,
IT'S A COMPLETE DISASTER, I'VE
BEEN SAYING THIS FOR 15 YEARS.
NOW IT'S RUN BY A MAN I WOULDN'T
HIRE TO WORK SECURITY AT A
PRESCHOOL.
>> HAVE ANY OF THE 42 ILLEGAL
MIGRANTS ON THE TERRORIST WATCH
LIST BEEN RELEASED INTO THE
UNITED STATES?
>> I DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER TO
YOUR QUESTION.
>> Laura: IF YOU THINK THE DHS
EXISTS TO PROTECT THE HOMELAND,
YOU HURT HIM, THAT'S MISTAKEN.
THIS MISSION IS TO PROTECT THE
ELITES FROM THE HOMELAND, TO
SUBDUE AND SURVEILLED THE PEOPLE
WHO PAY THEIR SALARY.
LAST TIME I CHECKED, 221,000
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS ACROSS OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER, THEY WERE
ENCOUNTERED BY OUR BORDER
PATROL, THIS WAS IN THE MONTH
OF MARCH ALONE, THAT IS THE
RECORD I BELIEVE.
CONGRATULATIONS MR. SECRETARY.
NO THREAT TO THE HOMELAND, NO
WORRIES AT ALL.
THIS FUELS OUR DRUG EPIDEMIC IT
PUTS CARTELS IN CHARGE, KILLS
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF AMERICANS
IN FENTANYL OVERDOSES BUT THE
ONLY THING THAT DHS IS WORRIED
ABOUT IS YOU.
THEY WANT TO SHUT DOWN
CONSERVATIVE SPEECH, BAN
ANYTHING NEGATIVE SAID ABOUT
BIDEN AND THE DEMOCRATS, AND
PUNISH YOU IF THEY THINK YOU GET
OUT OF LINE.
THEY CALL THAT DOMESTIC
TERRORISM, IF YOU POST SOMETHING
THEY DON'T LIKE -- BELIEVE ME,
THAT'S WHAT THEY THINK.
I'M TELLING YOU SOMEONE LIKE
RAND PAUL SHOULD HAVE THE SENATE
LAWYERS WRITE A LETTER TO PUT
THE ADMINISTRATION ON NOTICE,
THAT REPUBLICANS BELIEVE THE
OFFICE OF DISINFORMATION HAS
BEEN SET UP TO HARASS AND
INTIMIDATE LAW-ABIDING AMERICANS
WHO ARE SIMPLY, PEACEFULLY
EXERCISING THEIR CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHTS.
THEY BELIEVE IT'S BEING HEADED
BY A RANK IDEOLOGUE AND A GENDER
ACTIVIST, AND THE REPUBLICANS
ALSO SHOULD ANNOUNCE THAT IF ANY
AMERICAN FEELS THREATENED OR ANY
WAY TARGETED BY THE DHS,
REPUBLICANS WILL FIGHT TOOTH AND
NAIL TO DEFEND THE RIGHTS.
REMEMBER, THE GOVERNMENT USED
9/11 TO JUSTIFY THE CREATION OF
DHS WHICH TURNED INTO THIS HUGE
SURVEILLANCE APPARATUS IN THE
UNITED STATES.
THE GOVERNMENT THEN USED CODED
TO LOCK US DOWN AND MANDATE
VACCINES AND CLOSE SCHOOLS AND
EVEN CHURCHES.
EVEN NOW, MANY OF THESE SAME
PEOPLE ARE USING JANUARY 6TH A
SIMILARLY NEFARIOUS WAY, AS A
WAY TO LIMIT FREEDOM.
ATTEND A CONSERVATIVE EVENT,
TRUMP RALLY?
YOU BETTER WATCH OUT.
EVEN POST ABOUT IT OR MAYBE SOME
CRITICISM OF THE BY THE
ADMINISTRATION, MAYBE YOU'RE
ANGRY ON THE INTERNET.
DOING SO COULD END YOU UP ON
SOME TYPE OF WATCH LIST.
MAY BE YOU LOSE YOUR JOB, MAYBE
YOU WILL BE PUT IN JAIL.
THE MORE THIS GOES ON, THE MORE
OBVIOUS IT IS THAT THESE PEOPLE
DO NOT KNOW HOW TO GOVERN
AMERICA, LOOK AT THE ECONOMIC
NEWS THIS WEEK.
THE MORE DESPERATE DEMOCRATS
WILL BECOME TO SILENCE THE
OPPOSITION, TO PUNISH THE
DOMESTIC ENEMIES.
THIS IS WHY THEY ARE FREAKING
OUT ABOUT ELON MUSK AND TWITTER.
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY, IT WAS AN IDEA WHOSE
TIME HAS LONG SINCE EXPIRED.
SHOULD'VE BEEN BROKEN UP MANY,
MANY YEARS AGO, THEY COULD'VE
STREAMLINED INTELLIGENCE WITHOUT
CREATING A NEW SUPER STATE STYLE
CONTROL OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
IT'S TOO BIG, TOO UNWIELDY, IT
WASTES TOO MUCH MONEY, AND T